[Applause]
[Music]
let's imagine if you can that you've got
to organize a party for a bunch of
eleven-year-old boys and you want to
apply the three different types of
system that apply in nature well if you
assume the party's chaotic the children
are acting at random you might as well
buy the drugs and alcohols for the
children can go on a personal experience
of self-discovery your house may don't
burn down in the process but what does
that matter
all property is theft and it was
socially constructed in the first place
and I have friends in California who've
tried this I don't recommend it the
recovery cost is high but it's
legitimate approach on the other hand
the one will be more familiar with is
the ordered systems approach here it's
of critical importance to construct
clearly articulated learning objectives
in advance of the party itself
the learning objective should of course
be aligned with the mission statement
for education in a society to which you
belong ideally you should print the
learning objectives off on motivational
posters with pictures of eagles soaring
over valleys and water dropping into
ponds and place those around the room
where you can hold the party you then
produce a project plan for the party the
project plan should have clear
milestones throughout the party against
which you can measure progress against
ideal party outcome once you've done
that you know the senior adult can start
the party with the motivational video
tape after all you don't want the
children wasting time in play which
isn't aligned with the learning
objectives of the party itself and then
they should use PowerPoint to
demonstrate their personal commitment to
the objectives of the party and to show
the children how pocket money is linked
to the achievement of the milestone
targets now of course the third approach
the complex the approach is even simpler
here we draw a line in the sand known as
a boundary in complexity theory and we
turn to the children and say cross 30
little bastards and you die and one of
the things you learn pretty fast as now
they'll tis the value of flexible
negotiable boundaries because rigid
boundaries have a habit of becoming
brittle and break in catastrophic ly
we then use catalytic probes and I'm
deliberately using the jargon of
complexity theory now football a
videotape a barbecue a computer game
something which will stimulate a pattern
of activity which is called an attractor
and if it's a beneficial attractor we
stabilize it we amplify it if it's a
negative attractor we dampen it or
destroy it very quickly so what we do is
we manage the emergence of beneficial
coherence within attractors within
boundaries and in that simple phrase we
see the promise of complexity theory for
organizations and government alike
you